ah my lips stuck to the throat of my
teeth
and so thirsty
i can't walk anymore okay
insta360 just sent me their new x3
camera and as you know i'm a huge insta
360 fan so far they've made filmmaking
breeze for me but then again i haven't
put myself in really gnarly conditions
and put this camera to the ultimate test
like surviving the hottest day in north
america in 30 years dangerous heat wave
is gripping the region harsh jabs from
mother nature the hottest day in the
city since 1988. before moving on i'll
be giving away this insta360 x3 camera
along with the accessories i used to
shoot this video to one person who
subscribes turns the notifications bolt
on and lets me know that you've done so
in the comments below
this is my good friend jp who also
happens to be a pilot
[Music]
he just built an entire plane from
scratch and then flew it here to san
francisco from south africa
he also said he's willing to fly us into
the heart of california's death valley
which tomorrow will be of record high
temperatures
[Music]
we thought it would be super
entertaining to add our good friend tom
who's british who also can't deal with
the heat whatsoever
what is this
these are all well this here is a is
like a mini air conditioning unit
it's not even a hot day are you actually
joking being out here for two minutes
look my head's wet
well get some rest i'll see you guys
tomorrow
i think so
poppy
it's already
98. death valley is supposedly going to
get to 118 degrees fahrenheit which is
47 degrees celsius
that's going to be a really epic heat
test for the insta360 and just for the
human body firstly i'm going to attach
the insta360 x3 to the front with the
new 5.7 k half inch sensor
in sensor
half inch sensor
you're thinking the word half inch front
stroll that captures 5.7 k you just have
to leave it there and then you know you
can do it in post just
one angle yet a whole bunch of angles
[Music]
this shot was done with the 4k single
lens mode on the x3 it's this mode which
will make insta360 the future of the
action camera
now it's all about this
no
what
you know what's glitching me out is that
you built this thing you gotta remember
i flew this thing from south africa i
was in a crazy storm where the wings
should have definitely broken off and
they did okay
[Music]
yeah i can hardly breathe this is a
really stupid idea we've been here for
all of two minutes and i'm burning
in all honesty i don't think i can last
much longer i'm just gonna do a few
insta 360 shots and then we're out of
here
but first lunch
what's really exciting and new about the
x3 is that in the bullet time mode the
matrix the matrix spinning mode it
shoots at 120 frames per second in 4k i
think that's exciting i'm really
excited to see that
[Music]
it's a road
we're going to fly out of here
cloudy airplanes need cool thick air to
fly and this is too hot and so
can we try
the only thing we can do is like you and
tom way here yeah and i'll fire up and
give it a go we'll see if we can get out
of here
we are getting out of here
i hope this works
[Music]
that does not look good
and
we're stuck dude
you [ __ ] lying bruh
not good
oh yeah yeah
i got
the shadow here
anywhere where it's not hot
there's nowhere to go there's literally
nowhere to go
[Music]
where the hell is tom going
i don't know bri over it
there's a massive dust storm right there
those dust devils are moving way faster
than i should be we got ourselves in a
in a bit of a situation here
[Music]
i think we should go look for tom dude
which way did he go again
[Music]
i think it was that way but also in that
way
tom's missing
we have no water
and we can't get out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if i'm the cersei i can only imagine how
thirsty time must be
it's so warm
it's like it's pissing on me
i think we should just wait there
until time comes back
[Music]
the new 8k time lapse mode opens up an
entirely new world
dude you left here and you were so
pissed off
i was we walked the whole way down there
to look for you sorry man it's been a
six hour i'm sorry
why are you making that sound
what sound you keep going like
was that just me did you become a lizard
definitely have not become a lizard yeah
[Laughter]
why are you looking like that bro are
you crawling around like that bro you're
crawling around but beautiful places
we're going to capture it in 360.
not like that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like i'm dying
today
today
how's that flying eh it was it was
intense actually it was probably some of
the most intense flying i've done in a
while i knew it and i partly he lied to
us i didn't i just had it downplayed
because
yeah he wouldn't have got us in the
airplane otherwise dude yes that is she
what did you guys think of the insta360
then loved it loved it there's an
amazing camera i mean i can't believe
that it survived the heat i can't
believe it survived dan mace well and i
can't also believe that it also survived
strapped to the side of an airplane
so yeah if you're a content creator like
jp or just some random like tom
[Laughter]
this camera's for you yeah i highly
recommend you getting an insta 360 x3
like right now you're gonna look
enthused
okay
so yeah click on the link in my
description right now to check it out
and remember if you comment below
letting me know that you've subscribed
and turn your notifications below on you
stand a chance to win this insta 360 x3
that one this exact one yeah really yeah
isn't that cool
why are you saying because we break the
thing
oh i'll i mean we'll fix it yeah we
abused it a bit i think it just fell off
it as well by the way oh [ __ ] i was on
the ground other than that don't forget
you're awesome bruh and i'll see you
soon
[Music]
you